[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mardi est 16
avril une réouverture attendue après
trois ans de travaux depuis ce mardi 16
avril le public peut à nouveau découvrir
le grand appartement de la reine
les quatre salles qui le composent ont
retrouvé de leur superbe
c'est une expérience inédite qui vous
attend assister à une représentation
dans le noir et or voient une pierre
avec vous bande les yeux pour mieux
attirer votre attention sur l' écoute
big blind à rebours est jouée au théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines humour et
improvisation ben et arnaud tsamere
était à la ferme du manet la semaine
dernière pour une soirée survoltée
nous parlerons aussi à la littérature
avec le pavé du canal qui accueille ce
samedi cinq auteurs locaux et les
médiathèques saint-quentinoise nous
évoquerons l'univers du livre jeunesse
mais tout d'abord un mot de patrimoine
les images ont fait le tour du monde la
cathédrale notre dame de paris en proie
aux flammes hier soir lundi 15 avril
sollicité la fondation du patrimoine a
décidé de lancer une collecte
international pour sa reconstruction et
si vous souhaitez y participer le site
internet s'affiche à l'écran
l'événement a bien sûr fait réagir le
monde culturel yvelinois c'est une
profonde émotion et un soutien pour les
équipes de la cathédrale de la part du
château de versailles une émotion
partagée par catherine pégard la
présidente du château exprimé hier soir
son soutien à ceux qui luttent pour
sauver ce symbole indissociable de
l'histoire
geneviève dichamp la directrice du
théâtre montansier a confié sa tristesse
infinie et sa confiance absolue envers
les pompiers engagés
françois de mazières le maire de
versailles a quant à lui partagé son
immense douleur et c'est avec un coeur
brisé et qu'omar sy a choisi de partager
son émotion sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est ce dernier tweet que vous voyez à
l'écran avec moi en plateau deux de nos
invités du magazine mais avant de parler
de vos actualités respectifs peut-être
un mot sur cet incendie
quelle place quelle image a pour vous la
cathédrale notre dame de paris
les dates d'abord peut être valérie
papier
2 mai du réseau des médiathèques notre
dame c'est toute notre histoire
c'est à la fois notre histoire
littéraire et notre histoire avec un
grand h
et c'est hier soir sidéré complètement
médusés que j'ai écouté cette
information d'abord la radio et ensuite
j'ai vu les flammes à la télévision etc
c'est vraiment très triste j'ai des
enfants qui ont pleuré en voyant ces
images parce qu'ils ont été bercés par
l'histoire de notre dame de quasimodo
d'esmeralda et c'est cette une partie
d'eux-mêmes qui s'emballe et voire même
qu'hier avec alors vous êtes directeur
artistique et musiciens c'est le
patrimoine en fait partout c'est un peu
de bien commun le voir partir enfin
partir pas complètement sa joie éclate
il est restera blanc fait le bâtiment
situé en compte la structure s'est
effectivement notre patrimoine commun
donc à partir du moment où quelque chose
le patrimoine comme est fragilisée
forcément c'est d'une grande tristesse
et effectivement le c'était une course
très très impressionnant mais l'image
est donc vous comprenez cet engouement
les dons actuels qui sont déjà à plus de
3 millions à pour les particuliers ah
oui c'est vraiment des rendements
surprenant c'est vrai oui que que ça
même atteint 4 millions c'est ce qu'on
appelle un stand à temps c'est
impressionnant du compte pour la
restauration quand même après tout cumul
y en a plus de 60 700 millions
là c'est les dons partie paris sur la
fondation du patrimoine deux heures en
quelques âmes faut que ça continue
exact merci à tous les deux valérie
pavillon vous retrouve dans quelques
instants pour votre actualité
et enfin c'est justement à l'actualité
culturelle yvelinoise c'était l'un des
lieux de vie officielle et publique des
souffrances est aussi l'un des lieux les
plus visités du château de versailles le
grand appartement de la reine rousset
port troupes au public ce mardi
césar elle l'heure est à la réouverture
après trois ans de travaux le grand
appartement de la reine a retrouvé de sa
superbe de la salle des gardes à la
chambre les quatre salles ont été
rénovés
la salle des gardes
elle a fait l'objet d'un très gros
chantier de restauration avec un mécénat
important d american friends of
versailles et de la société des amis de
versailles donc l'instauration du
plafond peint est un des grands plafonds
peints du château de noël couapel et
puis restauration complète aussi des
parois du décor de marbre des plombs
doré de toute cette ambiance très louis
xiv
dans la chambre de la reine témoin de
trois règnes c'est le plafond qui
dévoile ses secrets
lourdement rénové au 19e siècle y révèle
aujourd'hui des subtilités et du
sionisme
jusqu'à une époque récente les
restaurateurs n'avaient pas beaucoup de
scrupules et avait tendance à recouvrir
très largement plutôt que de dégager la
crasse et de restituer l'original on a
beaucoup recouvert repeints et on s'est
rendu compte que ce plafond finalement
ne ressemblait plus à ce qu'il était à
l'origine
si la chambre était la dernière pièce de
l'appartement au temps des souverains la
visite se fera en sens inverse
en arrivant de la galerie des glaces
c'est à chants sacrés chrétiens qui
prend son essor aux états unis le gospel
permettait d'exprimer de partager sa
ferveur religieuse
un style qui inspire de nombreuses
chorales et coeur celui de soul gospel
sera versailles ce week end
regardez il en termine est un milieu
chrétien composé au xviiie siècle l'une
des chansons les plus populaires du
répertoire américain
ces chanteurs appartiennent à ce gospel
un collectif d'artistes créée en 2009
pour que le gospel parce que c'est le
message qui traduit en fait un c'est un
message d'amour un message de paix et
sage qui réunit
et je pense qu'on a vraiment besoin
justement actuellement et donc c'est ce
qui prenons aussi un petit peu dans
notre coeur donc un vrai message
derrière depuis dix ans ce collectif a
rassemblé une quarantaine d'artistes une
demi douzaine d'entre eux sera au centre
lui de versailles le samedi 20 avril
prochain en grand voyage où on va
vraiment passé par différents stades
différents styles de la capella du piano
voix du gospel un peu plusieurs bains un
peu plus moderne donc il y en a bien qui
en a vraiment pour tout le monde ferait
damon père tranquille
schaars moon s'est rendu dans artistes
qui sont rang dans ce milieu là et qui
prendra aussi le même message
professionnels et semi-professionnels
ces chanteurs revisiteront des standards
et partageront leur amour du gospel
autant de jazz de soul et de r'n'b
[Musique]
allez les
m
on vous retrouve erwan caradec pour
parler de votre actualité alors ce
mercredi vous serez au théâtre de saint
quentin davy pour une création originale
vous êtes le directeur artistique
propose pour profiter pleinement de
blind un titre du spectacle vous bander
les yeux
depuis bourg il exactement c'est à dire
qu'en fait c'est une jauge réduite de
public il ya soixante personnes qu'on
amène à l'intérieur d'un espace qui ne
connaissent pas les yeux bandés et après
on est quatre musiciens alors tourner
autour si je puis dire et dans l'idée la
raison pour laquelle j'ai voulu faire ça
c'est que comme l'avait été à la télé ça
va être assez fort compréhensible si on
prenait un violoniste qui prend son
violon et qui amène son archet vers ses
cordes nous simplement le fait de le
voir faire ça vous vous avez déjà lu
leçon avant que la cloche et touche la
corne
donc en fait vous avant d'entendre vous
lisez le sont parce qu'il met en fait
quand on est de globalement dans une
culture de l'image et vous faites de la
télévision donc si je suis bien placé
pour le dire
généralement la vue l'emportent sur les
autres sens et le fait de retirer la vue
on redonne toute l'importance à louis et
c'était ça qui m'intéressait c'était de
déjà de redonner le son comme premier
moyen de communes de des changes et
après donc du coup de multiplier les
clés comment les profondeurs les
distances entre le musicien et publient
ce qui fait qu'en fait on ne les paie si
tout ça est qu on le rend aussi
différent suivant l'endroit où on se
trouve dans la pièce et ça rend le plus
peut être plus attentifs à chercher
alors ça c'est ce que j'ai dit non le
plot dit le spectateur sait ce qu'il
fait au départ c'est qui le il essaie de
rendre l'image du son qu'il reçoit
et comme on a complexifié la chose au
bout d'un moment on obligé d'admettre on
appelle est arrivé donc on oublie de
recevoir la proposition sans se dire
qu'on va comprendre et disséquer le son
de la proposition elle même s'est
globalement le rendu global qui nous
intéresse
alors vous l'avez dit vous êtes quatre
mois j'ai vu que vous amener le public à
se livrer ses dires vous avez un retour
du public
alors oui la raison est toute simple si
vous allez un concert ou un spectacle
vous êtes généralement dans la salle
avec le les artistes au plateau est donc
généralement vous les actifs se livrent
aux personnes qui viennent les voir là
dans blind celle inverse
vous arrivez pour un spectacle on vous
bande les yeux quand vous avez dans un
espace que vous connaissez pas et là
tout d'un coup c'est vous qui vous
livrer aux musiciens qui vous tourne
autour vous ne savez pas ce qu'ils font
c'est paquet lequel un instrument ils
utilisent et donc du coup la façon de ce
livret est inversé c'est plus le
musicien qu'il se livre si on livre
parce qu'on est en train de le faire
mais de là qu'on demande enfin on est
amateur de direction c'est du public
pour vous vers quelle personne allait
peut-être plus facilement on va vers
tout le monde mais par contre nous on
voit les réactions et parce que même si
vous vous avez les yeux bandés mais pas
nous donc ce qui fait qu'on peut
effectivement interagir avec la personne
et sud est généralement ont sûrement
joué effectivement est justement la
première réaction la plus
fréquente de sursaut le genre de point
il peut y avoir des effectifs
il ya ça il ya des personnes qui sont
dans leurs fauteuils et qui vont tendre
qui vont aller vers vers le sont
d'autres personnes qui sont complètement
impassible qui vous vraiment ne bouge
pas et il y en a d'autres qui sont qui
sourit qui manifestent de simplement sur
le bas du visage qu'on peut voir qu'ils
manifestent ils manifestent une vraie
déception
donc ça évidemment on rêver on s'en
amuse bien sûr vous voyez que vous vous
déplacez vous jouez dans différents
endroits ce que vous vous servez de ces
mouvements j'ai le corps devient toute l
ancien no stress c'était c'est aussi
l'intérêt c'est que on peut jouer très
très près de l'auditeur mais vraiment
proche dit très très précis à quelques
centimètres et on peut aussi frôlé on
peut donc ce qu'on fait mais aussi
beaucoup c'est à dire quand on se
déplace en permanence à l'intérieur du
dispositif ce qui fait qu'on vous fait
vous êtes aussi bras c'est autant par le
sont que par les mouvements ce qui fait
qu'en fait tout ça amène à un moment on
est obligé de se laisser aller à lorsque
vous laissez le public dans le suspense
complet avec des interrogations ou vous
dévoiler quelques secrets
à la fin c'était quelques instruments ou
généralement n'ont généralement non en
fait parce que du coup je sais pas
comment dire y'a pas il n'y a pas une
façon de lire cette pièce dans le sens
où on n'amène pas un contenu qui est
lisible pour tout le monde c'est à dire
avec une forme de citations culturel qui
serait commune et du coup on en aurait
tous la même lecture
ce qui m'intéressait c'est qu'on fasse
une proposition justement qu'ils ne
définissent pas l'endroit où en est nos
instruments fait c'est qu'un moyen
j'ai retenu une certaine manière ça
pourrait être d'autre instrument pas
forcément les volets ben emmerson ça
m'arrangerait et enfin en tout cas ça
pourrait être d'autre instrument ça
marcherait pareil ce qui est important
c'est plutôt de commandes d'amener une
musique qui laisse à chacun se faire sa
propre histoire et d'une certaine
manière ça nous appartient plus à ce
moment là ce qui était la première chose
qu'on a fait quand on l'a créée à brest
on a collecté des paroles pour savoir ce
que les gens pouvaient en pensée et en
fait on s'est rendu compte que pour des
mêmes scène de cette pièce des personnes
avaient des réactions complètement poser
la plus drôle étant qu'il y a
deux personnes qui sont venues me voir à
la fin de la pièce on dit à tel moment
j'avais l'impression d'être dans un dans
un grand cadran calèche avec quelque
chose très féerique et une autre
personne à côté disait qu'ils se
retrouvaient sous l'eau entre l'armée
russe et l'armée comment américaine et
qui se tirer des missiles et c'était la
même chose s'est elle y parle exactement
de même du beau moment de la pièce les
trucs chacun pourra se faire sa propre
interprétation
merci à voir avec alors blind est à
découvrir au théâtre de 50 ans débute ce
mercredi 17 avril il y a deux
représentations qui sont donnés à 15
heures à 17 heures dans 20 heures de
20h30 même le bandeau lui est bon et le
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
vous propose aussi une soirée à
contretemps pour vous interroger sur
l'expérience d'être spectateur ce
mercredi de cet abri vous pourrez
échanger que marie-agnès sevestre
ancienne directrice scène nationale de
doué et christian ruby philosophe et
enseignant un mot d'humour à présent ami
de longue date il se lance en duo en
2013 dans on n'demande qu'à en rire
l'émission de laurent ruquier sur france
2 depuis ben et arnaud tsamere ont du
mal à se quitter plateaux télé
collaboration des médias sportifs et
maintenant sur scène après une première
date à plaisir en 2018 il était de
retour dans les yvelines
le 12 avril dernier pour une soirée à
montigny le bretonneux une ferme du
manei l'ars arriviez dans le public mais
aussi sur scène ben et arnaud tsamere
ont régalé leurs spectateurs de leur
humour absurde et partager leur plaisir
d'être ensemble
john quelles sont les conséquences du
break site sur le quotidien des
britanniques ou à tahar ouattar icônes
ci queen's ibrix ait fort for the basic
people in the life of all the day
what
parfois je suis très spectateurs de ben
quand on est sur scène et j'ai envie
j'ai envie de me marrer avec le public
parce qu'il me fait rire il faut un
petit peu lutter aussi contre ça pour
pas que ça devienne juste de dollars de
potes qui rit alors tu payes d'une place
ou alors j'ai pas dans le public
du coup c'est de faire du monde un
spectacle crescendo à l'humour de plus
en plus loufoques ben est un autre sa
mère forme lors du ou en 2013 dans on
n'demande qu'à en rire de la télé à la
scène ses créations leur semblait
évidente
je sais pas si les gens s'attendaient
tellement à ce qu'on fasse un truc
ensemble mais nous on avait l'impression
que oui on en parlait depuis longtemps
quoi voilà c'était enfin bref c'était
surtout pour nous de dire enfin sur
scène parce qu'on a nous deux c'est
vraiment une envie après avoir fait
beaucoup de qualité des digressions de
l'improvisation les artistes font de
chaque représentation une création
inédite
ben et arnaud tsamere sont en tournée
jusqu'au mois de juin et je pense à tous
ces jeunes du lycée
pour regarder on va regarder vers doha
un autre talents repérés notamment grâce
à une demande qu'à en rire arnaud cosson
et sur la scène de la royale factory de
versailles avec cyril le doublé il joue
sur la naïveté la mauvaise foi ou la
folie douce de leurs personnages à
découvrir samedi 18 avril les yvelines
est plutôt saint-quentin-en-yvelines
regorge d'auteurs le pavé du canal en
est bien conscient et le samedi 20 avril
la librairie iny montaigne ouvre ses
portes pour un nouveau show chapitre de
son lisez local pauline amine bonjour
bonjour vous êtes la directrice de la
librairie
déjà pourquoi mettre à l'honneur des
auteurs locaux mais la librairie à 30
ans cette année ça fait 30 ans que l'on
se veut être un acteur culturel
dynamique et le promouvoir la vie locale
et la culture au sein de la communauté
de communes
alors ce samedi ses cinq acteurs auteurs
locaux pardo qui sont reçus pourquoi eux
en particulier c'est lé dann tresses
très sollicité en soit plusieurs
plusieurs manuscrits ou plusieurs
exemplaires par semaine d'auteurs locaux
donc on fait un choix en fait chaque
livre est confiée aux libraires ou à la
libraire concernés par le sujet et sont
les libraires qui font le choix de
recevoir ses auteurs et puis ma ceux qui
ne sont pas reçus cette fois ci sur la
rupture
la fois suivante c'est quand même des
auteurs coup de coeur pour les églises
soit ce sont des auteurs coup de coeur
soit ce sont des auteurs pour qui il
sait que le jour de la rencontre des
électeurs seront intéressés par le sujet
la manière dont il est traité mais là
aussi pour faire le lien entre les
auteurs et leurs futurs lecteurs
il ya des styles très divers on a une
autobiographie un peu d'histoire du
développement à l'arsenal on essaye
comme on est très sollicités on essaye
de faire des thèmes là se disait local
est consacrée plutôt sciences humaines
d'une manière un petit peu large
on a effectivement un un témoignage sur
l'histoire d'un jeune garçon sous
l'occupation
on va avoir un livre plus de
développement personnel autour de
l'énergie des couleurs on a aussi un
livre bien plus scientifique et qui
explique les enjeux de l'informatique
voilà c'est assez varié on essaye de
rester dans un tête quand même un petit
peu et comment ça va se passer
concrètement ce sont différents stands
où il ya une présentation successives
alors en fait il ya deux sessions de
rencontres de 15h à 17h nous recevons
trois auteurs et de 17 heures à 19
heures deux autres auteurs voilà ils
sont présents en même temps sur une
table commune et chacun est libre de
présenter son ouvrage est de discuter
avec les personnes présentes et ce sont
des échanges imagine peut-être des
dédicaces si certains sont déjà suivis
oui oui c'est essentiellement des
dédicaces
voilà mais parce que le temps ne nous
permet pas d'organiser une vraie
rencontre avec chacun des auteurs mais
voilà ils sont tout à fait prêts à
disputer avec avec leurs lecteurs leurs
futurs lecteurs ou leurs électeurs déjà
acquis il ya des parmi ces cinq auteurs
il ya des au ghana qui ont écrit des
ouvrages assez originaux je pense
notamment à stéphanie herter certain que
je prononce bien son nom de famille qui
écrit qui écrit autour d'un président
incognito
oui le sujet le livre avait été choisi
bien avant la fameuse affaire des gilet
jaune
voilà l imagine en fait une rencontre
entre alors on imagine elle même une
femme voilà de la classe moyenne qu'à
une vie tout à fait normale et elle
invite le président mâcon à venir
partager son quotidien
connaître ses difficultés ses joies ses
peines et voilà deux qui se met un petit
peu à son niveau et voilà pour essayer
de lui faire comprendre les différents
enjeux du quotidien pour plein de gens
on va dire un petit mot sur un autre
ouvrage parce que l'auteur lui même ne
sera pas vraiment là physiquement
puisqu'il est décédé en 2014 c'est le
fameux jeune garçon pendant l'occupation
s'agit de naguère la guerre qui est de
michel pariset en fait c'est son fils
qui a décidé d'éditer ce manuscrit
voient la main de son père il a décidé
de lui rendre hommage comme ça et de
donner vie à cet écrit voilà nous suit
le destin d'un petit garçon sous
l'occupation
ce à la fois un témoignage est une
manière d'avoir un regard sur la petite
histoire dans la grande histoire durant
la seconde guerre mondiale et alors pour
ceux qui rateraient ce rendez vous est
ce que la prochaine date est déjà connu
oui il ya une seconde session au match
juin le 20 juin si je me trompe pas qui
est davantage consacré à la littérature
ou la six auteurs seront présents
sénateurs et pour ne rien rater le site
du de la librairie s'est affiché à
l'écran
merci pauline alors pour cette nouvelle
édition du lycée local en rendez vous ce
samedi 20 avril à 15h à la librairie le
pavé du canal à quelque chose d'inédit
maintenant louer une oeuvre pour un ou
deux mois c'est le service inédit
proposé par des étudiants de
l'université versailles saint quentin
avec leur artothèque ils veulent
démocratiser l'art contemporain les
pauvres oeuvres disponibles sont à
découvrir au sein de la bibliothèque
universitaire elles sont rassemblés dans
l'exposition renaissance un mot avec
l'une des étudiantes à l'origine du
projet c'est vraiment de mettre l'art au
coeur du quotidien
des étudiants mais aussi des habitants
de la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
et plus largement des entreprises
puisque notre vue de ce site de les
toucher et l'artothèque est ouverte tous
les mercredis et samedis de 13h à 16h on
continue son exil mais avec notre nouvel
invité avait les faveurs vont alors vous
êtes agent du patrimoine dans le réseau
des médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines avec vous on va parler d'un
événement qui a débuté le 9 avril
dernier et qui court jusqu'au 18 mai
donc on a le temps de se rattraper
ces graines de papier une immersion dans
le monde de l'illustration
je laisse tout à fait oui nous avons
commencé avec une exposition de d'un
maison d'édition et l'envers et plus
particulièrement de leur collection
pont-des-arts et cette exposition a lieu
à la bibliothèque à la médiathèque
anatole france à travers jusqu'au 9 mai
sur tout un événement comme ça c'est
être l'illustration jeune ministre à feu
très important dans le livre jeunesse
abbas et c'est une part très très
importante du tout petits aux plus
grands ils fulminent c'est un moyen
d'entrer dans la lecture pour longtemps
la lecture dans la lecture d'image et
dans la lecture du texte c'est vraiment
pluridisciplinaire on pourrait dire
comme ça et cette exposition va ensuite
un petit peu voyagé puisqu'elle va aller
plaisir au château des salles armande
béjart du le 11 mai jusqu'au 18 mai
voilà et effectivement c'est important
cette année on s'est attachés et à
essayer de voir les maisons d'édition
qui entrent et faisait entrer les
enfants dans les oeuvres d'art avec
l'art avec un grand a
par l'intermédiaire d'artistes aussi
puisque nous
nous illustrateurs sont aussi des
artistes ils sont trois à être présents
cette année sébastien twh/an
l'illustrateur parisien vanessa y est
elle aussi parisienne et christine day
to day toi alors comment on les avait
découverts et bien par la collection
pont-des-arts essentiellement cette
année pour moi c'est une découverte que
c'est sébastien tout âge que je ne
connaissais on voit justement à l'élan
c'est un artiste urbain qui fait plein
de choses en dehors de l'illustration de
livres pour enfants et il fait partie de
groupe i là il fait de la publicité
il est très actif et cette année voilà
il son livre paraît là en ce moment
c'est un nouveau format pour la maison
d'édition et l'envers et c'est un livre
jeu et par ce biais là c'est faire
connaître aux enfants le street art et
reader art l'art urbain
voilà peut-être qu'à dire que l'image
que vous les parents peuvent mais en
plus ces trois artistes qui seront aussi
en atelier où ils vont les enfants eux
mêmes vous pour créer leurs
illustrations là c'est intéressant parce
que
de l'artiste qui sur papier glacé on va
pouvoir le rencontrer et travailler avec
lui et créer quelque chose créer une
oeuvre aussi petite soit elle mais une
oeuvre quand même et il sera demain
mercredi
anatole france sébastien twh avec les
enfants pour une journée d'ateliers
voilà merci valérie pas via leurs
graines de papier c'est jusqu'au 18 mai
dans les médiathèques de saint quentin
en yvelines
le programme complet puisqu'on n'a pas
tout raconter et à retrouver sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
et je vous propose maintenant de passer
à notre page agenda
[Musique]
des confessions des portraits des scènes
autour d'un seul et même thème la
maternité au théâtre espace que je de
plaisir les mom vous racontent leur
quotidien un spectacle pour les mamans
les futures mamans mais pas seulement
regardez la peine et la genevoise est
donc là c'est qu'ils rentrent 3 dans le
règlement ferdinand et ma fille qui
tient le tuyau d'arrosage à bout de bras
avec ce petit sourire psycho maniaque
qu'elle a parfois et qui fout les jetons
j'ai fait un câble j'ai arraché deux
tuyaux des mains et je l'aspergé droit à
plein de figure est ce que ça te fait on
plante de l'eau glacée de rigueur à
s'occuper des enfants devrait être une
chose tout à fait naturel totaux du
sagou c'est à peu près aussi naturel que
tu as du bo sur un fil en longueur et
qui ont peur le monument est aujourd'hui
d'actualité mais notre dame de paris
inspire aussi les artistes au théâtre
montansier à versailles
cinq comédiens vous font revivre le
célèbre roman de victor hugo
regardez
attaché en hausse à volonté
hamelin bras et lui même en voit dans la
sauver mon corps des cauchemars de la
nuit mais il a volé mook je voudrais
l'europe plus belles qui vous pourrez
vous pâmer d'amour
oh oui allons manger du gâteau je crois
ce que je vois et dieu est amour alors
je crois en lui un dernier rendez vous à
ne pas manquer à maurepas c'est un
concert rock jeune public qui vous
attend avec une il ya un bug les
chanteurs s'intéresse à ces petits
grains de sable qui rythment la vie des
enfants à vivre en famille regarder
[Musique]
promet de sang
allez bien gco
c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]